À découvrir aussi dans l’exposition,
des plaques fossiles de plantes et d’insectes
qui expliquent un peu tout cet écosystème ?
On a la chance, dans ces régions du Liaoning,
d’avoir bien sûr, pu retrouver ces dinosaures à plumes
mais aussi toute la faune et la flore qui était associée.
Et dans cette flore, qu’est-ce qu’on a trouvé ?
On a trouvé pour la première fois la plus ancienne fleur connue au monde.
C’est l’Archaefructus, dont on voit un superbe spécimen,
c'est une plante à fleurs.
On est devant la première fleur au monde, c’est quand même extraordinaire,
on est à 120-125 millions d’années.
Evidemment, il ne faut pas s’imaginer une rose ou un pétunia,
c’est véritablement une ébauche de fleur
mais pour un botaniste il va reconnaitre les éléments principaux
qui constituent une fleur.
Et, alors en quelques centaines de milliers d’années,
on voit que toutes ces plantes à fleurs
se répartissent dans tout le monde.
C’est-à-dire que cela va très très vite,
au point qu’on se demande s’il n’y a pas eu
plusieurs foyers d’apparition des plantes à fleurs.
Et encore, en quelques millions d’années
vont apparaitre les premiers magnolias
c’est-à-dire les premiers arbres qui portent des fleurs.
Tout ça va très très vite
et on a en quelque sorte figé un écosystème
dans lequel on va avoir des dinosaures à plumes,
des oiseaux, on va avoir des crocodiles,
on va avoir les premiers mammifères placentaires.
On va avoir donc des fleurs
et qui dit fleurs dit pollinisation
donc les premiers pollinisateurs,
les premiers hyménoptères, ces insectes pollinisateurs.
On a tout un système qui se met en place
il y a environ 120 millions d’années.
On peut dire qu’on retrouve actuellement cet écosystème,
bien sûr, les espèces ont changé,
on n’a plus de dinosaures à plumes mais on a toujours les oiseaux,
on a toujours les insectes,
les abeilles sont toujours là,
elles sont apparues il y a 120 millions d’années elles aussi.
On a cet écosystème qui se met en place au Crétacé
et qu’on retrouve encore maintenant
même si les espèces d’animaux ont changé.